he made a massive comeback today did I
miss Gary definitely making a little
closer in his match against Wesley so
it's after yesterday's contest he was
definitely in a big hole but making a
dent today bit of a comeback Anish tell
us about how you've been doing and of
course today's comeback
yeah I've had an interesting match so
far I find a little bit of a pity that
in the first two days he played very
well I played not so well but there were
a few games where I gave some points
unnecessarily that's a pity I mean won
one game I I made an opening miss
misjudgment I saw some game of
Hospitaller Hikaru I think and I saw at
some point Blake had a good position but
I didn't realize that what he did in the
very opening was bad so I followed that
game and it was terrible idea and I lost
very quickly there was a c4 c5 before I
don't remember at some point yes there
was and there was also one game where I
lost a dead drone rookin game in a blitz
game that is also a pity so I mean
Sepideh to give up give up these points
other than that he really played better
than me the first two days so should
have won of course anyway but not with
such a score and yesterday I think I did
better because I think the position was
not complicated and I think it suits me
better than than him yesterday in fact
the position was not so complicated and
it means the way I played it we quickly
got some very clear positions and I were
pushed two times you know when you're
down so much like I was at some point to
start over pressing and I was over
present and trying to create something
out of nothing and today I could
actually create something so I was happy
to do it again a couple games at least
you're still down on a big score with
the Blitz to go you got to win 6-2 just
to tie it up but your thoughts about
going into tomorrow well I had after
yesterday had 2 goals 1 goal was to have
a day good enough that you invited into
the city that's accomplished another was
to play good enough to go into the last
day with 8 blitz games having a
theoretical chance of tying the match so
that also is achieved
yeah obviously I'm not thinking about
the score I mean if you see how many
games I lost first two days you don't
necessarily
think about coming back but you just
want to get some good games in and I
don't know when he firstly will start
getting nervous maybe if you'll see this
$10,000 in his head you know going going
around I don't know if he's affected by
that but if he eased and I'll have a
chance tomorrow otherwise obviously
player as good as him he's I mean to say
that he's a heavy favorite is a huge
understatement blitz games to come well
that effect of the play given that it's
only blitz now no rapid games at all
yeah I think what we'll probably have to
do is come up with more ideas which are
I mean what we did so far we try to go
as deep as we can obviously without the
computers and come up with some
interesting concept and develop that
concept quite a lot and probably what
we'll do tomorrow is there will be eight
games right so do before white gamer
will try to come up with four different
ideas whereas yeah like I said today we
just picked one let's say the my first
idea was a four and we spent almost a
whole hour analyzing a four very quickly
I dismissed it 45 and I might have sort
of sort of understimated to move e5
which I saw looked at it a bit but like
many other teams who focused on a 45 if
I've been focused on number four but
then okay of course if I knew I'll have
to play like for white games I would you
know look a bit at the for-loop that if
or perhaps a little bit of 93 c4 and so
on so I professional be little different
and yeah and the games obviously I
thought the rabbit was a lot of fun
because you had the opportunity to
really come up with ideas still and in
blades yes you don't really come up with
ideas so much as you just make some
moves you know which is also fun but
it's nice it's nice that you know you
think four to three minutes they come up
with interesting ways to develop your
pieces it's refreshing you're actually
going to get two positions tomorrow so
to get to cracks and with each position
with the Y eights before the game today
you told me that you would see this
position before that were you joking I
couldn't really tell yeah I also told
Jennifer that I've analyzed 532
positions and that's where I had to fly
to San Luis
okay obviously I was making a joke but
yesterday we had a funny thing with with
my ii i i i told him that you know it
would be fun if this random generator if
it wouldn't be really random so i
thought okay let's pick that position
that we had left off and click this you
know and click this random generator and
see maybe you'll get lucky we'll get the
same position today but the random
generator is really around the
microphone okay we just analyze one
position just for fun it was not this
one no it's very hard to guess and i
have to say so it's also quite fun
actually to analyze these positions with
the computer it's different than without
it and here we only analyze with all the
computer this is also fun to analyze it
with computer so we could also perhaps
next time it's also an idea to think
that maybe you give us a positional day
in advance it's it's both are possible
it's been an interesting match so far
interesting matches in fact and we're
always happy to have you in studio so
keep playing well yeah I prefer when I
show up here not having lost all the
games so this way inviting only when I'm
worse all right well good luck tomorrow
thank you thank you